le président du groupe socialiste au
sénat est l'invité de preuves par 3
bonsoir didier guillaume soir et merci
d'être avec nous donc pour ce
rendez-vous de public sénat avec l'
agence france-presse
comme chaque semaine et bien vous
répondrez à trois grandes interpellation
la première bien sûr au sujet de la loi
travail est ce un nouveau départ comme
le prétend manuel valls ou plutôt le
crash d'une réforme qui ne fallait six
litres a aucune embauche
selon les patrons alors tenez vous bien
que des critiques sortent désormais
également de la bouche des manuels
macron qui regrette que certaines
mesures est été estomaqué deuxième
question la révision constitutionnelle
examiné à partir de demain par le sénat
qui veut maintenir sa version cette
révision constitutionnelle est elle
vouée à l'échec
vous répondrez à mickaël szames est sans
fin troisième question pour 2017
françois hollande est il le bon candidat
stéphanie le rouge vous interrogera sur
la présidentielle première partie
première question didier guillaume vous
sentez encore le souffle
de quel souffle me parlent eux la brise
libéral que la première mouture de la
loi travail faisait souffler sur le code
du travail
non mais moi je ne parle plus de la
première mouture ou des premières
discussions nous avons eu il ya deux ans
maintenant sur comment réformer le code
du travail le rapport combrexelle et
d'autres rapports badinter pour savoir
comment nous avançons il ya un texte qui
a été envoyée au conseil d'état ce texte
a eu des interrogations de la part de
gens de gauche comme de droite la part
du patronat comme des syndicats de
salariés
ce texte aujourd'hui il a été revu de
fond en comble c'est un vrai nouveau
départ comme l'a dit le premier ministre
à ses curés crash mais c'est loin d'être
un crash parce que lorsque l'on fait le
compte personnel d'activité lorsque l'on
fait la garantie jeunes ces deux mesures
écoutez bien ce que je vais vous dire
sans des plus grandes mesures sociales
depuis 30 ans jamais nous n'aurons fait
cela jamais nous ne permettrons aux
jeunes d'avoir une garantie comme
celle-là ce qui pourrait s'apparenter
revenu universel le camp de personnel
d'activité la sécurité sociale
professionnelle demandé depuis des
lustres par tout le monde
nous la mettons en place la ces mesures
sont très forts et en même temps qui
aurait dit à six mois que nous
réformions le code du travail comme nous
l'avons fait
jamais personne parce que dans ce pays
il ya ceux qui gesticule il ya ceux qui
veulent que rien ne bouge
allons-nous nous voulons bouger et en
même temps parce qu'il n'ya pas être
aveugle de sourds le gouvernement le
président de la république a entendu ce
que disaient les organisations
syndicales ce que disaient les jeunes ce
que disaient les français et nous sommes
revenus sur un certain nombre de mesures
oui alors ce que nous avons à une
ambition c'est de réformer le pays avec
les syndicats réformistes
nous voulons mettre en place les
fondations les bases d'un nouveau
contrat social appuyé sur un nouveau
dieu à leur réussite et ça vous citez
vous alliez les syndicats réformistes
bien sûr on penserait la cfdt ne sont
pas nos alliés non non non nous ne
sommes pas un intérêt qu elle le soir
nous ne sommes pas dans cette mesure là
nous travaillons avec eux parce que nous
contrairement à d'autres nous pensons
que les corps intermédiaires
représentent quelques chaleurs à propre
et nous voulons nous adresser à toutes
les organisations
mais évidemment à ceux qui se veulent
réformistes comme au medef alors que
croire aujourd'hui croire aujourd'hui
qu'on peut réformer le droit du travail
sans s'appuyer à la fois sur les
syndicats de salariés et sur le syndicat
patronal sur les syndicats patronaux
l'insee falher à propos du syndicat
réformiste
il est aujourd'hui une prise de position
assez forte qui est celle d' emmanuel
macron je vous le disais tout à l'heure
il a pris la parole aujourd'hui à cannes
pour déplorer que justement pour
satisfaire les syndicats réformistes
certaine mesure et est escamoté du
projet initial et notamment le
plafonnement des indemnités prud'homale
comment est-ce que vous interprétez
aujourd'hui cette position du ministre
de l'économie qui espère le
rétablissement de certaines mesures lors
du débat parlementaire je suis née
michel grossiord et je vous crois sur
parole
oui je n'ai rien lu rien entendre et je
vous rapporte je ne sais pas le nom mais
les retenues d'eau par des congères sont
pas je ne vais pas qu'eric donc je ne
ferai aucun commentaire parce que je ne
sais pas de quoi vous me parlez
je vous fais entièrement confiance donc
je ne dirai rien simplement sur la marée
vise à sion voyez des prud'hommes comme
c'était évoqué c'était une mesure qui
nous semblait importante parce qu'il y
avait beaucoup de différences entre les
régions les départements et enfin je
rappelle qu'il ne s'agit pas de
l'indemnité les
était prévu dans le texte les salariés
continueront c'était simplement pour
limiter les choses excessives bien une
demande de nombreux syndicats a été nous
n'en voulons pas ce n'est pas bon nous
nous n'avancerons pas bien dans cette
direction
le gouvernement a donc fait le choix de
ne plus mettre les barèmes tels qu'ils
étaient oui mais de les mettre indicatif
et au juge de le faire almen d'accord
mais ça c'est un recul annuel macron
c'est un recul prévu que répondez vous
au ministre de l'économie je vous
réponds à vous mêmes que dans la loi
macron nous avions voté au sénat comme à
l'assemblée nationale
les barèmes dans les prud'hommes ça
avait été retoquée par le conseil
constitutionnel parce qu'il y avait une
différence entre les petites et les
grandes entreprises
ce qu'on demandait beaucoup de syndicats
de salariés est ce que je demande moi au
gouvernement c'est de très vite prendre
les décrets concernant ce futur texte et
nous verrons que in fine et cela
permettra de donner à la fois dessine
pas de crainte pour les employeurs mais
la préservation des intérêts des
salariés
ce que nous voulons c'est l' équilibre
ce double équilibre je disais il ya
quelques mois dans un travail
d'explication vous entendre il faut
émission qui légalement d'apaisement we
did you may cette réforme du droit du
travail mais c'est un un travail
d'apaisement qui est mis à bas
aujourd'hui par le ministre de
l'économie
non mais attendez pouvoir me parler à 50
fois je ne sais pas de quoi vous parlez
je n'ai rien lu mais je vous ai dit mes
sources et non mais vous sucer pas qui
sont vos sources
ce sont des confrères qui étaient à bord
le monde c'est des trucs au foot chez
pas quoi et les mini lundi que certaines
mesures de bon sens devront être rétabli
lors du débat parlementaire que c'est
une perspective vers le mans que c'est
le père le mans jouera son rôle
évidemment comme il doit le jouer mais
simplement ce que je veux vous dire ici
ce soir d'un preuves par 3 sur la chaîne
parlementaire
c'est tout simplement que lorsqu'il ya
désaccord avec les syndicats concernant
le travail de droit du travail
alors on ne peut pas les remettre en
cause
après au niveau parlementaire il ya
plein d'autres choses sur lesquelles le
parlement devra travailler sur les
licenciements sur l'efficacité sur le
le cpa sur la garantie jeunes mais
lorsqu'il est d accord partenariaux
entre les syndicats et le gouvernement
le mieux c'est de le laisser sa salle le
dialogue social n'existe plus je ne
voudrais pas que les mêmes n'ont pas de
nouveaux reculs genre ailleurs mais
c'est pas un recul en mai 2000 n'y a pas
d'autre les licenciements et qu il n'y a
pas d'audience et lui donne vos amis
stylistes les frondeurs notamment qu'ils
ne sont pas satisfaits du maintien de la
mesure sur les licenciements durant les
sociétés les grands groupes qui ont des
sites en france
ce que je retiens entendu
malheureusement je le regrette mais les
frondeurs sont à peu près d'accord sur
rien avec ce que fait le gouvernement
mais peu importe moi je veux pas
stigmatiser ou parler des frondeurs ou
je ne sait trop sur les licenciements
économiques est un engagement qui a été
pris hier par le premier ministre qui
serait de dire une vérification forte
sur d'éventuels licenciements par la
fonction oui par le juge
non seulement le groupe et les frondeurs
disent que ça ne suffit pas alors
s'attaquer à ces villages moi ce qui
m'importe
dans cette dans ce nouveau départ
c'était d'afficher deux choses un
équilibre l'equilibre de nouveaux droits
pour les salariés
nous en avons parlé et l' équilibre de
plus de fluidité et d'efficacité pour
les entreprises et il fallait répondre à
ce 4 août et à ceux qui souffrent alors
sur le deuxième a répondu sur le
deuxième point je vous propose d'écouter
ce que dit le président de la cgpme
françois à cela pour lui le texte de
compromis donc neutre elle se traduira
par aucune nouvelle embauche notamment
pour les petits patrons en l'écoutent
on a entendu les jeunes très bien on
entendu les surloyers très bien sauf que
ceux qui créent l'emploi en france à
savoir les pme les tpe et les patrons de
pme c'est quand même eux qui signe un
contrat de travail
en tout cas il a été entendu c'est un
vrai problème dans ce pays c'est à dire
qu'on a une culture économie qui est 00
patate voilà c'est à dire que lorsqu'on
est malheureusement chef d'entreprise de
pme
eh bien on est largué au milieu de la
nature et débrouillez vous non nous
colloque on nous colle cette image de
patrons et alors que ben pâton pnj ou
minutes et salariés de ses salariés une
réaction allant vers 1,10 la cg oui je
le rassure et visite il ya des choses
qu'il peut utiliser dans la loi pour
gérer sereinement je regrette cette
position parce que moi ce qui m'importe
c'est bien les tpe les pme évidemment
les grands groupes mais les tpe et les
pme
et le président de la cgpme devrait
quand même reconnaître un certain nombre
de choses maintenant
non mais le cic eux les 41 milliards de
baisses de charges aux entreprises
ça les concerne et moi dans le
département je voulais déjà dit ici sur
ce plateau
il ya plein de chefs d'entreprises de
pme tpe qui ne serais plus là
aujourd'hui journal bâlois du travail
oui mais c'est important aussi et ça ça
concerne les pme les tpe sur 7 sur cette
loi
le fait de dire que en décentralise de
dialogue social que ça peut se faire
dans l'entreprise que s'il n'ya pas s'il
ya moins de 30% de représentation
syndicale on en pourra le faire par
référendum représentant plus de 50% des
employés
c'est pas en faveur des pme et des tpe
donc un bon compromis
michel rossi aurait un bon compromis
c'est quand à l'arrivée personne née
avec son drapeau en disant j'ai gagné
j'ai gagné j'ai gagné il n'y a qu'une
chose qui nous importe nous c'est sûr la
france qui gagnent les français les
jeunes et les chômeurs parce que
l'objectif de ce projet de loi c'est
moins de précarité plus de travail plus
de facilité d'embauché et plus
d'efficacité dans l'économie et je crois
que nous y arrivons les syndicats
réformistes une cité là la cfdt il ya
aussi la cfe cgc il est à la cftc
la fage de plus le plus grand angle est
la plus grande organisation de jeunes de
notre pays et y est favorable
et monsieur gattaz le président du du
medef évidemment aurait voulu qu'on
aille encore plus loin que la première
mouture encore plus loin mais enfin nous
sommes dans les king alors j'aimerais
ville a été totalement opposé je vais me
risquer à une dernière citation
d'emmanuel macron qui est dit
aujourd'hui à force de mesures
protectrices on ne protège pas les
jeunes au travail on les protège du
travail et sa saignée d'où ça vient
toujours de la merde encore ok là dessus
des 10 km est ce que vous craignez que
vous créiez que lier à nouveau la
contestation dans la rue du côté des
autres syndicats on parle que des
syndicats réformistes ans mais il ya
aussi la cgt il ya il faut il ya du neuf
mais bien sûr vous avez des craintes
mais bien sûr mais c'est pas une crainte
c'est que
le mouvement va continuer puisque la cgt
fo et l'unef appellent à manifester les
étudiants demain ou après demain et puis
surtout le 31 mars
mais c'est pour ça que de lierre
jusqu'au 31 mars et jusqu'au conseil des
ministres il faut expliquer il faut
expliquer que cette loi est un hymne à
la jeunesse est faite pour elle parce
que nous voulons au 0 précarité pour les
jeunes grâce à la garantie jeunes nous y
arriverons nous tous les jeunes 900
mille jeunes neuf cent mille jeunes
auront les moyens de faire une formation
ce n'était pas assez le cas jusqu'à
maintenant les jeunes ont intérêt à cela
et puis par rapport aux salariés les
salariés ont tout intérêt à ce que les
entreprises puissent avoir un peu plus
de fluidité et d'efficacité
enfin quand on regarde ce qui se passe
dans les pme les tpe vous n'avez pas
convaincre parce que je vais interroger
sur les contestataires est ce que vous
créiez encore une explosion sociale bien
je vous réponds oui mais en vain
brillant en expliquant donc je pense
qu'un joueur mais il ya un risque parce
que des mouvements de grève mais nous en
grève on sait pas comment ils commencent
on sait pas comment ils finissent mais
c'est par l'explication par la
conviction que nous voulons essayer
d'arriver à montrer à ceux qui ceux qui
se sentent représentés nombreux derrière
la cgt derrière et faux derrière l'une
est de se dire regardez ce qui
réellement la loi
bien trop souvent on parle du contexte
et pas du texte est en période de
grandes difficultés à perdre ou
l'exécutif aujourd'hui on le voit bien
est affaibli par un certain nombre de
critiques et contraintes européennes au
moment où le printemps arrivant la crise
des réfugiés va battre son plein nous va
poser plein de problèmes et bien avons
besoin d'unité et de rassemblement et
mon rôle comme le rôle de tous les
responsables n'a jamais été aussi grand
vous allez parler d'une conjointe de
fait les rythmes sont assez grand mais
il faut expliquer peut-être tout à leur
parlerons nous dans la deuxième partie
de ce qui s'est passé hier au conseil
des ministres d'agriculture avant parler
à bruxelles ben oui mais il faudrait en
parlera des raisons d'avancer versement
personne n'en parle
on va parler de la crise ce qui ne va
pas dans ce pays et moi j'aimerais qu'on
ce que l'on soit positif dans une france
des structures et dans une france
divisée avec des français qui doute avec
des français qui souffrent il faut
répondre dans un terreau alors et c'est
dans ce cadre-là du travail de la loi du
social
cette loi travail elle va aller dans ce
sens vous ne voulez pas entendre parler
de la loi première mouture mais les
républicains on le sait était prêt à la
voter
aujourd'hui ils ne voteront pas de tv
lcd et écouter eric woerth c'était ce
matin dans territoire d'impôts et voulu
répondre et quand on dit d'un projet
qu'il est équilibré ça s'annonce mal
fait ce qu un projet équilibré si plus
rien c'est comme l'eau tiède
ça s'annonce vraiment très mal c'est ce
qu'ils disent comme le terme de
compromis est un mauvais termes on peut
pas la france n'est pas un compromis
on doit pouvoir réformer notre pays en
faisant ce qu'on doit faire et parce
qu'on doit faire à moitié à un quart ou
aux deux tiers
alors là c'est le rejet total de mes
premiers je répondrais deux choses à
eric woerth
d'abord c'est un spécialiste deux ont
réussi à mettre des gens dans la rue et
a fracassé la politique de monsieur
sarkozy de monsieur woerth c'est de
faire fracasser les français entre eux
c'est de fracasser les syndicats c'est
de fracasser le dialogue social c'est
d'enlever les corps intermédiaires
nous avons là la décision et nous y
allons les propositions de nicolas
sarkozy de monsieur woerth sur diminué
de 300 mille le nombre de fonctionnaires
diminue et fonctionnaires territoriaux
sans aucune discussion ce n'est pas du
tout ce que nous voulons faire et puis
deuxièmement nous l'aurions voter si
faut arrêter de nous faire le cinéma
peut-être parlerions nous tout à l'heure
de la lède de la loi constitutionnelle
avant républicains sont toujours
d'accord faisait fi de tribus dame est
nommé en votre récit ils n'ont jamais
fait le moindre pas en avant la main
tendue avec leur gouvernement pour
travailler il a bien compris avoue
rejeté l'idée d'un crash de la loi dite
médicis et pas même daigné un ratage
initial et écouter d'ailleurs ce que je
dis à ce sujet la ministre qui porte le
texte
mariam et le conneries qui reprend
d'ailleurs la thématique du compromis et
qui le justifie moi je crois que
chercher un compromis
c'était utile dans la période sur
laquelle nous avons travaillé parce que
en effet le démarrage a été raté
puisqu'il n'y a pas eu de pédagogie sur
la loi on ne réforme pas dans la
brutalité
donc nous avons cherché un compromis un
compromis c'est un pas en avant un pas
vers l'autre
c'est justement l'inversé précisément
l'inversé qu'un recul on ne réforme pas
dans la brutalité
son adressée à manuel valls non non pas
du tout ce que je sais ce que je viens
de vous dire moi je partage que
dit myriam el khomri cette loi était mal
parti oui elle est bien là la brutalité
quelle brutalité elle est partie sur un
texte un prétexte en avance mais conseil
d'état il ya eu des négociations pendant
plus de six mois pendant plus de six
mois on ne le dit pas tout ça parce que
ça va vite parce qu'on veut vraiment
mettre dans le film que nous sommes raté
la ministre l'a dit oui mais nous
aurions dû démarrer différemment oui
mais notre objectif c'est le coq oui est
ce que nous sommes et chacun fait un pas
en avant et c'est comme cela qu'on
répondra l'on ne constate pas à cette
occasion là un changement comme un bâti
tude presque de personnalités de manuel
valls souvenez vous il ya très peu de
temps il nous disait j'irai jusqu'au
bout et à une parle d'un dialogue de
compromis des coûteux il s'est changé
quand verrons nous allons nous allons
aller jusqu'au bout nous allons faire
voter ce texte qui est essentielle mais
nous le faisons dans le dialogue
le premier ministre et le président de
la république se sont aperçus certains
disent trop tard mais peu importe
ils s'en sont aperçus qu'il manquait du
dialogue qu'il fallait recommencer une
deuxième mouture il s'en soit quinze
jours les deux parce qu on pourrait
avoir l'impression que là la réforme
telle qu'elle apparaît aujourd'hui et
plus le fruit d'une synthèse hollandaise
jour quinze jours de décalage pour un
texte c'est pas énorme pour en arriver à
ce qui s'est passé hier à matignon où un
certain nombre d'organisations
syndicales ont dit que ça allait et où
le medef a dit que c'est pas si mal que
ça je pense que nous allons avancer dans
cette direction faire acte dans le
relais c'est à dire n'y a pas d'euro 49
3 non non mais là ça a été ça a été une
erreur de dire cela nous l'avons tous
reconnu dans fait d'ailleurs le mot
qu'un 9,3 n'a pas cédé prononcer mais
nous prenons nos responsabilités
c'était clair ce n'est pas bien on ne
brutalise pas le vainqueur et parlement
le 49-3 existe mais je ne suis pas
favorable à cela ce texte
il doit passer sans le cas 9 3 pour le
bien des françaises et des français et
de l'économie française
allez deuxième partie de l'émission des
légumes deuxième question la révision
constitutionnelle donc examiné à partir
de demain au sénat qui veut maintenir sa
version
cette révision est elle vouée à l'échec
et vous allez répondre à mickels à metz
dans un instant alors que le ministre en
charge des relations avec le parlement
laisse entendre que l'on n'est pas loin
d'un enterrement on écoute jean marie
et le texte n'est pas encore voté par le
sénat je sais pas ce que fera
définitivement le sénat en première
lecture ce que je vois c'est que le
texte qui est sorti en commission n'est
pas pour nous acceptable je le dis très
nettement donc s'il n'y a pas si le
sénat ne modifie pas son état d'esprit
nous n'accepterons pas il ya eu des
débats nous avons trouvé un compromis
qui a eu une majorité à gauche et à
droite à l'assemblée nationale ce
compromis est le bon compromis
nous ne voulons pas ouvrir les
polémiques autour de ce texte si le
sénat ne fait et ne comprend pas qu'il
faut arrêter les polémiques
alors je pense qu'effectivement il y
aura des difficultés
en tout cas nous n'accepterons pas de
rouvrir les polémiques nous rejoindre en
forme et elle
bonsoir michel vergnier dédié au soir
quand on attend jean marie le guen aux
syndicats la révision elle est morte et
enterrée
je ne sais pas ce que fera la droite
sénatoriale ce que je pense ce que je
sais en tout cas c'est qu'il faut se
replacer le 16 novembre dernier
je préfère une à droite s'est repassé le
10 novembre mais attendez d'eux le
discours du congrès de versailles
la situation post attentat est le fait
que le président la république ait su
rassembler la nation et faire des
propositions
il a fait des propositions au congrès un
premier texte a été sorti fin fin
décembre et on s'est aperçu l'encore
parce que nous avons des divergences
avec la droite sur la façon de nous
comporter que la version présentée par
le président de la république congrès de
versailles n'obtenait pas les 3 5e du
parlement
il a donc salué le président qui parle
de déchéance de nationalité qui parle
des binationaux et alors et alors
aujourd'hui on arrive à quoi comme qu'on
premier à l'assemblée nationale eh bien
justement je vais vous expliquer très
tranquillement je sois que aujourd'hui
vous chercher toutes les bisbilles tout
les petits célèbre matinée quoi et ne
pas parler du fond je pense que votre
génie visionnaire
je pense que nos téléspectateurs
s'intéresse au fond mais je vais vous
répondre
la proposition du président de la
république de l'assemblée du du congrès
de
de versailles après l'avoir mis sur la
table nous nous sommes aperçus il s'est
aperçu qu'il n'y avait pas de
possibilité d'avoir une majorité des
trois cinquièmes ni à gauche ni à droite
parce que je rappelle que pour qu'un
congrès ait lieu il faut que la droite
et la gauche
dans le cadre de l'unité nationale voulu
par nos concitoyens s'entendent il ya
donc eu visiblement plutôt à gauche qu'à
droite
à droite aussi vous étiez victime de vos
divisions home et du parti socialiste au
parti socialiste tout le monde n'était
pas favorable au texte à l'atterrissage
de l'assemblée nationale mais je
rappelle quand même que à droite et non
des moindres messieurs jupé messieurs
fillon qui ont beaucoup d'amis sénateurs
et sénatrices ici même dans cette maison
n'est pas favorable
donc il a fallu trouver une piste
d'atterrissage la piste d'atterrissage
c était de lire ce qui est mal vécu par
beaucoup de nos concitoyens par beaucoup
de parlementaires c'est de stigmatiser
les binationaux moi à titre personnel je
ne pensais pas aux binationaux je
pensais aux terroristes et c'est la
réflexion que j'ai sur la nation on peut
acquérir la nation française et j'en
suis très fier mais on peut aussi en
être déchu si on veut la détruire et
surfer n'a de terrorisme il se trouve si
vous permettait il se trouve que il n'y
avait pas de possibilité de 3/5 sur cet
extrait parce qu'il avait la
stigmatisation à l'assemblée nationale
le texte qui a été voté à plus des trois
cinquièmes par les socialistes et par le
groupe l'est républicain
c'est de ne plus stigmatiser mais au
risque de créer des apatrides lors
laissez moi finir c'est de ne plus
stigmatiser les binationaux n'ont pas du
tout de plus de stigmatiser des
binationaux essaie de faire une
déchéance plus globale et il faudra
traîner la patrie les attendait sauf si
on si on ratifie la nuit il a le droit
d'être de s'exprimer ne pas être tenus
pour quantité négligeable mais ici il
s'agit pas de quantité négligeable
il s'agit de positions politiques pour
arriver éventuellement ou non à un vote
au congrès et l'amendement qui
présentait par la majorité sénatoriale
pour pour revenir à la déchéance pour
les binationaux pour nous n'est plus
acceptable
elle n'est plus acceptable puisque
l'assemblée a fait un pas en avoir mais
c'est pas l'assemblée nationale face au
sénat puisque dans une répit
on continue c'est l'assemblée nationale
mais aborder cela vous pas trop des
sénateurs vous n'êtes pas d'accord non
je ne suis pas d'accord
chaque accord également avec une idée de
navettes de nouveaux compromis entre les
deux chambres
je ne suis pas d'accord parce qu'il faut
bien se rend là dessus ce qu'il faut
bien se rendre compte c'est qu'on est
dans un projet de loi constitutionnelle
pas un projet de loi ordinaire et un
projet de loi constitutionnelle
il n'y a pas de commission mixte
paritaire la navette peut durer six mois
donc quand le président du sénat dit les
discussions avec l'assemblée doivent se
faire après le vote en première lecture
au sénat riffs étrange je ne me le
permettrais pas de dire ça mais je
conteste cet argument parce que les
discussions elles ont démarré depuis le
16 novembre et que aujourd'hui les
sénateurs de la majorité sénatoriale
aurait pu essayer de se rapprocher de
l'assemblée peut-être différemment mais
à partir du moment où la posture des
républicains du président du sénat
c'est de dire on ne veut pas revenir là
dessus alors il sera difficile qu'il y
ait une qu'il y ait une victoire les
trois cinquièmes à l'édifice il n'y aura
pas de résistance je vous écoute si on
vous aidera pas du tout je vous dis que
si le sénat ne bougeait pas de
l'écriture ce qui va être présenté
demain alors il ne pourra pas y avoir
trois cinquièmes au cou qu'il y aurait
il n'y aura pas de révision là il peut y
avoir une révision sans ça mais je ne
place pas ma place et je ne me place pas
je ne place pas dans cette perspective
je pense que nous devrions pouvoir y
arriver mais je n'en sais rien on va
attendre les débats qui vont démarrer
demain je dis simplement que aujourd'hui
le sénat démarre beaucoup trop loin de
l'assemblée alors il ya des ententes
bien et comme entendre rire je ne dis
pas ça parce que l'assemblée a dit ça il
faut que le sénat se met derrière c'est
pas du tout le sujet le débat qui a eu à
l'assemblée nationale il est beaucoup
plus loin beaucoup plus fort un coup
plus grand que le sein de débats de
l'assemblée nationale bon alors lui
débarder l'ensemble des par le débat le
débat au sénat demain s'annonce animé
d'autant
mais quelle que l'ia des contestataires
chez les socialistes les oulémas levier
sur suis sénateur socialiste demande la
suppression de la déchéance
vous avez des frondeurs non mais
attendez vous avez des frondeurs mais si
c'est une mise à niveau qui est des
fraudeurs
mais ce n'est pas nouveau depuis le
début depuis le 16 novembre ou dans tout
cas le début janvier
nous savons très bien qu'il ya des
sénateurs socialistes qui ne sont pas
favorables avec la déchéance de
nationalité
comme il y avait des députés socialistes
comme il ya des scénars mais de là à des
moments comme ils avaient des sénateurs
républicains comme il ya des députés
république n va ne vous a pas échappé
quand même que nous sommes au sénat que
l'amendement qui va être déposée sera
votée par les signataires les 28 oui ou
peut-être 30 35 je n'en serais ou
peut-être plus mais qu'en tout cas il a
assez peu de chances de passer de vous
laisser faire évidemment mais nous en
avons discuté les personnes jouant sur
des sur ce sujet un sujet comme celui ci
si la liberté de conscience qui
l'emportent
par contre le groupe sera unanime
unanimes sur tous les autres sujets le
montant des biens unanime
alors je vous propose d'écouter
quelqu'un que vous connaissez bien à
votre groupe qui ne se présentent pas
d'ailleurs comme appartement au
mouvement des frondeurs socialiste et
bariza khiari qui est donc l dès le
départ et nous le dire a opposé à la
défense donald et dingo et mercier la
première urgence de l'amendé qui imite
si également aujourd'hui pour le retour
du droit de vote des étrangers elle veut
que ce soit remis sur la table en écoute
c'est une promesse de 30 ans
qui a été renouvelé par le président de
la république alors candidat c'est la
mesure numéro 63 et donc quand on parle
de constitution
on peut mettre ça dans la constitution
il suffit d'avoir la volonté de le faire
moi je n'en voudrai jamais à l'exécutif
d'échouer sur cette question j'ai lui en
veux de ne pas avoir essayé
on fait applaudir des milliers de
personnes dans les meetings sur la
question du droit de vote et quand il
faut y aller on n'y va pas on va au
contraire sur la déchéance
donc c'est pas possible pour moi c'est
une conception comme pour beaucoup
d'autres
une espagne frondeuse pas du tout avec
conviction qu est ce que vous lui
répondez non mais nous en avons parlé
d'un socialisme en parlait ce matin en
groupe et nous avons convenu que la
quasi unanimité du groupe voterait
contre cet amendement
parce que je comprends sa conviction ont
peut-être un jour cela sera-t-il bien
une chose qui suit avec ce que vous avez
partagé oui mais c'est normal il ya une
chose qui est sûre c'est que c'est
impossible d'inscrire dans la
constitution
donc voilà en tout cas le véhicule
législatif comme une colombe a je pense
qu'aujourd'hui ce n'est pas un bon signe
à donner et donc l'immense majorité
l'immense unanimité du groupe votera
contre cet amendement
bariza khiari défend ses convictions
nous ne sommes pas dans un débat
caporaliser les uns et les autres
peuvent avancer leurs convictions c'est
bien normal mais ce que je cherche moi
c'est de la cohérence et la cohérence
nous voulons qu'elles se fassent à
partir de la majorité sénatoriale
si elles nouent les deux mains qui
peuvent bouger de ce qu'ils vont voter
ou pas si la majorité sénatoriale nous
disait demain
voilà notre position nous ont demandé de
bouger c'est d'apprendre elle c'est à
prendre ou à laisser
alors qu'à l'assemblée nationale il ya
eu des efforts des deux côtés de la part
des républicains et des socialistes pour
arriver à un premier compromis s'il ne
bouge pas on arrêtera là et moi je ne
suis content si on ne verrait pas mais
moi il me semble que dans un cas comme
celui ci
si vraiment il ne bougeait pas je ne
serai pas favorable à ce qu'il y ait
encore des navettes une content comme
travers ma position elle est simple elle
est simple une navette maximum à
condition qu'on sache qu'ils puissent
qu'il ya une volonté d'avancer parce que
je vous dis franchement moi qui n'osent
l'arrêté quand je suis retourné dans le
département de la drôme ces trois
derniers
enfin vendredi samedi et dimanche
personne ne me parle de la déchéance de
nationalité
c'est très long c'est depuis novembre
donc il faut que ça se termine ce sujet
de suffisamment important sur l'occasion
de m'exprimer demain à la tribune du
sénat au nom du au nom du groupe
je porterai la parole du groupe y
compris les différences mais là
maintenant ça ne peut pas durer encore
six mois qu'ils sont très courtes
dernière sur la réforme de la
constitution
on parle de la réforme du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature pour y
introduire vous vous seriez favorable et
sur wii oui bien sûr donc il devrait y
avoir un congrès sur cette réforme de
ducos a mais il peut y avoir des
médecins où il peut y avoir un congrès
sur l'état d'urgence et la déchéance et
il y aura un congrès sur l'état
d'urgence et de chants sacrés le conseil
s'est pas de la magistrature je pense ça
serait bien je pense que là pour le coup
on n'est pas loin d'un accord mais là
l'assemblée le sénat font un pas la
valeur va l'autre l'un vers l'autre
alors on va parler maintenant des
dossiers zaricot l'a dit les lions vous
les suivait de très près on vous a vu
cette année encore bien sûr au salon
avec donc ces entorses à la politique
libérale et qui ont été obtenus à
bruxelles notamment par le ministre
français stéphane le foll
retour donc d'un peu de régulation pour
faire monter tenté en tous les cas vais
faire remonter le prix du lait ou encore
du port mais la fnsea par la voix de son
secrétaire général dominique barreau
estime que le mérite de ce revirement du
changement de pied en quelque sorte de
la commission revient d'abord aux
manifestants qu'on a vu sur leurs
tracteurs ces dernières semaines c'est
votre pression qui a permis ministre qui
il y a trois ans seulement n'avait pas
pris ce genre d'initiatives aujourd'hui
le ministre a pris l'initiative d'aller
voir son collègue allemand d'aller faire
le tour des capitales européennes
c'est comme ça que convoi
l'embryon d'une autre politique agricole
il a un peu tardé mais aussi à le
comprendre
en tout cas les résultats sont là
maintenant il faut qu'il devienne
appliquer rapidement pour que ça se
connaissent sur les exportations le
mérite revient la rue revient à qui vous
savez dans ce pays
c'est dur pour des gens de dire bravo à
quelqu'un bravo le foll voudra vont
enfin de bravo à elle comme riz ou bravo
pagola on vous dit
bravo le feu n'aurait pas fait mieux on
ne dit jamais ça mais enfin tant mieux
peu importe
y a que le résultat qui compte je trouve
dommage qu'il ne dise pas le ministre a
bien travaillé mais il représente 6 mai
peu avant sur le fond sur lefebvre au
tourisme et à mais sans le dire non
depuis depuis plus de six mois stéphane
le foll ici même au sénat au cours d'une
table ronde s'est battu pour imposer un
prix un prix minimum d'achat pour le
pour le port et pour le pour la viande
bovine
il se trouve que les apporteurs les
industriels ne l'ont refusé on ne peut
pas leur imposer
et là il a fallu faire pression et il a
fait pression puis la crise est
accentuée évidemment il ya beaucoup de
tracteurs dans la rue beaucoup de
détresse moi qui suis fils d'agriculteur
je peux pas me être être content de voir
de voir des agriculteurs qui sont
presque à la rue qui peuvent tout perdre
et compris leur maison enfin y'a pas
décision il n'y a pas une seule
profession en france
qui accepterait de vendre ses produits
inférieur au prix de revient
cette table qui conçut deux plateaux le
cas en public sénat l'a acheté elle l'a
achetée à quelqu'un qui est fixé un prix
quand vous voulez manger acheter du lait
vous voulez manger de la viande de porc
de la viande de boeuf on vous dit pas
combien vous la vendre du voilà comme je
voulais acheter
ce n'est pas possible donc le ministre a
fait monter très fortement l'attention
au niveau européen mais l'europe est
dirigée par la droite et libéral je
m'excuse de dire ça donc ils gagnent
comme non je parle des pays bas et donc
il fallait trouver une majorité de pays
la france ne l'a pas trouvée parce que
phil hogan le commissaire européen qui
est ultra libérale producteurs de lait
irlandais a fait partie de ceux qui
étaient contre les quotas laitiers
nous étions opposés à la fin des quotas
laitiers la droite francs
c'était pour et aujourd'hui on voit ce
qui se passe donc ce qui a été demandé
c'est d'arrêter
à certains endroits la surproduction
c'est pas des quotas qui sont remis
c'est à dire oui mais tant mieux moi
j'aimerais que les quotas reviennent je
vous dis franchement j'aimerais qu'on
veut remettre les quotas laitiers
parce que la cades aller jusque-là non
mais la fin des quotas laitiers
c'est la fin de beaucoup d'éleveurs dans
notre heure dans notre pays donc il y
aura ça il faut aller âge il faut alors
l'étiquetage c'est indispensable
le commissaire avait toujours refusé
jusque là quand le ministre lui demander
il a accepté pour trois ans c'est une
belle équipe d'acheter quoi ces viandes
de france produits transformés qui
seront mis sur tout l'est sur tous les
emballages qui monteront au français moi
j'en appelle au patriotisme de nos
concitoyens je suis sûr que les
françaises et les français qui font
leurs courses préférées
si tel qu'il cap et un centime de
centimes 3 centimes 10 centimes de plus
pour acheter de la viande française
plutôt que de l'acheter de l'alternance
revers à l'éthique dans sa série 2e
chose oui
la troisième chose c'est l'embargo russe
qui ne réglera pas tout mais il faut que
l'europe c'est pas la france qui est
d'essayer de l'embargo sur la russie
c'est l'europe
alors là ils arrêtent à bouger et donc
tant mieux notamment sur l'embargo
sanitaire enfin pourquoi nous avons
réussi à avancer parce que françois
hollande très fortement il y a
maintenant quinze jours auprès d'angela
merkel la chancelière allemande a dit
vous demandez vous demandez vous
demandez nous on a un objectif c'est
notre modèle français notre modèle amis
alors on en a on n'acceptera pas le
responsable de la fnsea bandas y en a il
un peu hésitant pour féliciter le
ministre il m'a fallu culture du
résultat
oui mais les résultats justement il est
critique aussi on la fnsea on attendait
aussi peut-être un plan massif de
soutien là ce sont des mesures
ponctuelles ce n'est pas un plan massif
on ne met pas d'argent
aujourd'hui 500 millions d'euros ont été
mis au conseil agricole de l'agriculture
de
il ya quelques semaines aujourd'hui
michel grossiord et l'europe
il ya un sujet majeur ce sont les
réfugiés c'est son devenir si le break 6
to pabr excite c'est de savoir tuer les
matches il ya encore une europe
l'agriculture c'est le secteur le plus
intégré et en europe et la politique
agricole commune
ces 38 milliards d'euros c'est le plus
gros montant attribué à des pays et nous
nous avons eu 10 milliards d'euros
c'était inespéré donc aujourd'hui on
sait que de l'europe on n'obtiendra pas
plus seul par contre ce qu'il faut
maintenant c'est du marché de l'économie
des prix et des accords et on va comme
consommateur surveiller les étiquettes
on vous le promet 13 ans alors en effet
déjà bhl êtes vous favorable aux
pesticides pour comprendre
stéphane le foll a signé une lettre
qu'il a envoyée aux parlementaires qui a
qu'il demande tout simplement de me pas
voté l'interdiction des pesticides c'est
l'un d'entre eux est néonicotinoïdes
voilà d'abeilles oui mais bien sûr que
non personne une lettre envoyée le
recensement des personnes défavorables
aux pesticides et je crois qu'il faut
aller dans cette direction stéphane le
foll a fait le gouvernement fait voter
ce qu'on appelle le plan ecophyto moins
50% de pesticides à l'horizon 2020 ou
2030 nous allons y arriver mais en même
temps en même temps il faut faire
attention à ce que ça ne met pas en
péril certaines cultures
aujourd'hui on a le problème des
néonicotinoïdes il ya déjà eu des
avancées sur le sujet stéphane le foll
d'après je pense que demain fera une
intervention il précise cet après midi
qu'il s'oppose à l'interdiction brutale
oui j'ai vu c'est ce que réclame
aujourd'hui vous donner un exemple
or sans 2014 d'utilisation de pesticides
free c'est pour ça que le plan ecophyto
ne marche pas assez bien et qu'il
foutait dans cette direction mais je
vais prendre un exemple chez moi dans le
troc com
oui mais d'accord chez mme berger les
cerises cette année il peut y avoir zéro
cerise par contre vous mangerez des
cerises et d'un grand d'espagne du
portugal
donc il ya des moments je pense que sur
ce secteur comme dans d'autres il faut
laisser de côté le dogmatisme et
regarder l'efficacité stéphane le foll
veut faire baisser le taux de nick 2
déco de produits phytosanitaires dans
l'est dans les champs etc
il est en train de le faire nous avons
noté des choses mais en même temps il
demande aussi que ce soit au niveau
européen créé décision soit prise parce
qu'il ya des pays qui ne le font pas et
on est tous jours après on vient se
plaindre auprès de nous il faut à régler
ce problème de néonicotinoïdes c'est
évident il faudra légiférer sur le sujet
pas bien peut-être pendant l'été calais
ni les ravages c'est pourtant rafale et
les ravages sont ils sont depuis ces
appâts de ravages mais c'est depuis des
années au savez aujourd'hui je ne
connais pas un agriculteur un
agriculteur qui se fait plaisir en
mettant des doses et des doses et des
doses ce qu'il faut aussi c'est avoir
des produits et peut-être qu'on va y
arriver
l'agroécologie c'est cela c'est ce que
veut le ministre le plan ecophyto et la
baisse de produits phytosanitaires nous
y arrivons c'est long plus long que
prévu mais ça va dans le bon sens qu'il
enclenche et ça c'est ce gouvernement
bon c'est pas le nôtre
merci beaucoup mais quelle troisième
partie de l'émission maintenant pour
2017 françois hollande est il le bon
candidat
stéphanie le rouge de lège plus là il va
vous poser la question dans un instant
elle va vous interroger sur la
présidentielle pour laquelle manuel
valls bien estime qu' évidemment le chef
de l'état est le candidat tout naturel
mais bien évidemment françois hollande
est le candidat légitime comme président
mais il suffit pas de proclamer suffit
d'aller faire un appel celui qui prend
la décision
c'est d'abord le président république
oui c'est d'abord entre françois
hollande et aujourd'hui c'est bien trop
tôt pour qu'ils prennent ce type
d'instrument je crois beaucoup moi cette
relation entre le président laura public
et les français je crois beaucoup à
celle relation directe et donc je suis
très méfiant à l'égard de toutes ces
initiatives qui constituerait au fond à
nous faire revenir à une autre
république
bonsoir ses fans et le rouge alors vos
questions sur le candidat légitime et
sur les autres aussi à notre invité que
manuel valls
dix après d'autres dans cette interview
que françois hollande est le candidat
naturel légitime
est ce que à force de le répéter pas
finalement ça montre pas plutôt que
c'est pas si évident non je crois que
c'est le candidat légitime mais que pour
les français aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
évident il faut appeler un chat un chat
aujourd'hui on quand on regarde la cote
de popularité du président la république
elle est faible elle est faible parce
que nous en parlions tout à l'heure la
france est déchiré structures et des
structures et parce que les mesures qui
sont prises vont dans le bon sens mais
ne porte pas assez leurs fruits le
chômage et l'économie et c'est parce que
nous voyons bien que la ligne de sens
politique que nous voulons donner n'est
pas assez compris parce que nous ne
sommes pas assez bons pour pour
l'expliquer donc il ne s'agit pas de
dire venez vivre un personnel pour les
sprem au jury et beaucoup de force et
jeh à ben oui mais je suis là pour ça
parce que si on ne fait pas d'efforts ça
ne marchera pas et d'ailleurs pour moi
c'est pas un effort c'est un plaisir
donc je pense vraiment que françois
hollande on va pas dire naturel parce
que ç'a porté chance à personne d'aucun
naturel mais le 15 est légitime il est
président sortant nous sommes dans la
vème république
nous ne sommes pas en espagne en italie
en allemagne ou c'est là c'est la
proportionnelle qui l'emportent nous
sommes un scrutin majoritaire
donc si françois hollande décide de se
représenter à l'élection présidentielle
de 2017
ce que je souhaite et ce que j'espère
alors il sera le suicidaire mais la
légitime et évidemment il n'y aura pas
de primaires à gauche
le président de la république se
présentant il va pas faire une primaire
et je pense qu'il peut y arriver
moi je ne suis pas suicidaire pardon il
était il est favorable mais à certaines
conditions en écoute l'ancien ministre
du travail
ça peut être une bonne occasion 6 ha à
la sortie qu'un seul candidat
une primaire de de toute la gauche j'ai
repris la formule donc des macros un
mélange tout et je pense que c'est une
bonne idée
il faut que tout le monde ait la volonté
quand on fait une primaire de débattre
et d'accepter les résultats de cette
prime si le président est candidat il
dira s'il se plie ou pas à la primaire
la primaire c'est aussi l'occasion de
d'affronter ou de confronter plus
exactement des lignes politiques
françois rebsamen
déclare plutôt pour la prière boutault
plus tôt il dit si le président les
candidats et s'il décide d'y aller
le ps travaille à cet épineux hypothèses
pour vous c'est complètement exclu non
mais je pas du tout comme le dit
françois rebsamen
s'il ya une primaire de toute la gauche
et que tout le monde dit le celui qui
est choisi sera notre candidat tout va
bien mais j'ai déjà entendu dans la
gauche ou dans la gauche de la gauche
que j'en ai plein chantier pas favorable
alors après quand on demande à françois
rebsamen
si la non participation de monsieur
mélenchon est rédhibitoire ai dit que
non ça peut aussi se faire oui bien sûr
bien sûr je vais plus loin donc après
monsieur pierre laurent notre collègue
sénateur secrétariat du parti communiste
français
dis moi je suis pour la primaire mais à
condition qu'il n'y ait pas de candidat
qui soutiennent le gouvernement actuel
que ceux appliqués environnement actuel
on va dire c'est pas grave mais ça fait
déjà 2 europe ecologie les verts j'ai
entendu le nouveau secrétaire général
par intérim dit nous on est d'accord
pour la primaire mais pas avec au
lendemain tout ça qu'est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire qu'il ya des gens qui
ne souhaitent pas que françois hollande
soit candidat que manuel valls le
candidat que ma chronique qui vous
voulez et qui veulent un candidat de la
gauche radicaux n'ont plus peut-être de
se suicider pour la guérir ou les
réponses et bien c'est bien dommage donc
je ne suis pas suffit d'ailleurs
et parce que je ne suis pas suicidaire
je pense qu'à un moment on les gens vont
choisir entre plusieurs projets si les
françaises et les français à vous savez
vous lui avez souhaité un projet plus
radicale plus à gauche
ils auraient pu le montrer dans toutes
les élections qui viennent de se passer
à aucune élection la gauche de la gauche
a fait de gros score et on nous disait
pas non plus c'est la démonstration
l'aveo dernière vous avez entièrement
raison c'est la raison pour laquelle
aujourd'hui rien n'est gagné et surtout
si on se divise tout sera perdu mais au
moment le plus faty dick élections
législatives partielles il y un an dans
le doubs en plein moment où alexis
tsipras ce était l'égérie de toute la
gauche de la gauche
ils étaient tous à athènes le soir de
son élection il voulait faire series à
la française ça n'a pas marché
je crois que les françaises et les
français ne veulent pas d'extrême pour
l'instant ils veulent plutôt une autre
extrême mais à l'arrivée il doit
confrontation de programme tout à
l'heure monsieur
10ème et pas de compromis en passe en
force nous nous pensons que lorsque la
confrontation va biographe dites vous
quand une confrontation de programmes en
vente afin de prouver le bilan du bilan
aussi bien sûr mais moi je suis fier du
bilan je suis fier de ce que nous avons
fait vous savez dans l'éducation
nationale
il n'y a plus une grève il ya plus une
manifestation devant vaincre et 60000
postes la droite dit c'est une erreur
nous le nous l'assumons la prime pour
l'emploi
la prime d'activité que nous venons de
créer deux millions et demi de français
ont un pouvoir d'achat amélioré par
rapport à cela
je pourrais en citer des exemples à
l'appel venait faire un quinquennat pour
rien comme l'a dit récemment gérard
larcher le président du sénat je
connaissais bien entre parce que dès mai
ensoleillé ce que dit gérard larrat
point de vue là on n'en met vous pouvez
apprécier une connerie je suis parfois
je ne suis pas d'accord avec ce qu'il
dit c'est facile de faire des effets de
manche et 2 lorsqu'on à la télévision de
taper puis apprécié de dire on va
essayer de travailler il dit aussi
président du sénat et le quinquennat a
commencé par un parjure le mot est très
fort de france hollande qui avait promis
la version de la cour dès 2013
que répondez vous à cela non je n'aurais
pour le moins chargé
je dis simplement que le président du
sénat qui le deuxième ou le troisième
personnage de de l'état devrait pas
faire ces expressions comme ça à la
télévision ou sur les plateaux parce que
ça ne crée pas le lier l'utile nationale
qu'il faut mais moi ce que je pense
c'est que ce quinquennat n'est pas pour
rien et nous assumerons notre bilan est
peut-être certains seront surpris
lorsque nous rappellerons tout cela et
j'aimerais d'ailleurs qui est plus de
socialiste qui parle du bilan
l'explication pour vous non mais
problème n'est pas la politique menée au
plus tard à la pédagogie n'a pas été
fait autour de problème n'est pas la
politique menée je pense que la
politique menée est la bonne je pense
par contre qu'il y à nous avons deux
soucis de problème 1 nous ne faisons pas
assez d'explications et surtout où
j'aurais dû dire d'eux nous ne faisons
pas assez expliqué les résultats
nous n'avons pas de résultats est ce
qu'il n'ya pas n'auront pas de résultat
donc à présent les français ne peuvent
pas dire abeilles sens très bien on va
voter pour eux parce que non ils ne
voudraient pas dans le déni dont body
nous n'avons pas de résultat néanmoins
on a une chance et françois hollande je
dis pas on a une chance je fais pas de
pronostics en a pas dans la boule de
cristal
judith pour l'instant nous n'avons pas
de résultats mais secteur par secteur
nous en avons nous parlons de chez ceux
du pas
de responsabilité pause entreprises nous
parlons de l'école la formation s'est
calmée essentielle tout à l'heure nous
avons parlé de la delà de la garantie
jeunes sur la sécurité
les lois ont été votées sécurité
renseignements terrorisme est très bon
et dur qui ont été mises en place par ce
gouvernement est parmi les plus récentes
on peut penser à la proposition qui a
été faite sur la déchéance de
nationalité
c'est sur la loi travail toutes ces
mesures n'étaient pas forcément dans le
programme du candidat hollande et même
certaines sont en contradiction avec des
mots qui avait pu avoir donc est ce que
est ce que le problème j'aime pas de là
aussi des almoravides n'y a aucune
contradiction qu'il espère que quand on
à françois hollande qui d'un côté 10 en
2006 que le problème n'est pas le code
du travail qui maintenant s'attaque au
code du travail
il s'expose pas justement fin 2006 à
part vous qui bossait beaucoup vos
dossiers sais pas si les français savent
ce qu'il a dit en 2006 ma faim c'est à
des années lumières 2006 qu'est ce qui
s'est passé depuis une crise sans
précédent dont on pensait qu'elle se
termine en 2012 et qu'elle a continué
nous avons eu un défaut d'explications
sur ce que nous avons trouvé en france
parce que quand même le déficit de la
sécurité sociale baisse il n'avait
jamais été aussi haut sous nicolas
sarkozy on est en pleine crise ebay ce
sans avoir dé rembourser sans avoir
changé notre modèle social
c'est une réalité la dette de notre pays
baisse alors que nicolas sarkozy ça a
été plus 600 milliards mais ça les
français ils ne le voient pas eux ils
voient ce qu'ils ont sur les discours
des bouquets premier le discours du
bourget ya aucun problème
notre ennemi c'est la finance est notre
ennemi continue à être la finance in
mais notre ennemi pas le cas du travail
non mais notre ennemi ce n'est pas les
patrons et lorsqu'on est dans une
situation nous sommes le seul pays en
europe
aujourd'hui le seul à ne pas créer
d'emploi alors il ne s'agit pas de
déréguler il s'agit au contraire
d'encadrer et changer le code du travail
le modifier aller de l'avant c'est pour
espérer demain pas aujourd'hui peut-être
même pas dans ce quinquennat mais nous
ne gérons pas avec
la lune est visée sur 2017 nous pensons
aux jeunes aux françaises et aux
français
à vous lire oui c'est de la langue de
bois c'est un lieu commun de dire ça
michel grossiord aurait pu le dire n'a
pas écouté ça parce que c'est la réalité
si françois hollande penser à son
éventuelle candidature à sa réélection
il n'aurait peut-être pas fait ça il
n'aurait pas fait la différence parce
qu'il savait qu'elle serait qu elle
casserait la gauche et la droite
il ne répète pas présenté le texte comme
cela parce qu'il savait qu'il n'était
pas consensuel mais ce texte elle
conneries travail il est essentiel il
n'est pas consensuelle nous allons
essayer de rassembler le plus largement
possible qu'il soit voté parce que
l'objectif c'est la baisse de la
précarité c'est la baisse du chômage
et c'est de penser aux jeunes il n'y a
pas assez de résultats vous avez raison
et nous allons tout faire pour qui les
résultats d'un équipement n'allez pas
vous écoute on a l'impression que vous
êtes déjà en campagne un an pour 2017
avec des thèmes qui se dessine qu'elle
serait un peu la ligne de la neurologie
moi je voulais parler programme contre
programme alors comment est ce que ce
serait mais attendez les français
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas en 2010 et agua
tous les sondages succès au deuxième
tour ceux qui n'y sont pas ce qu'ils
montrent ce qu'ils descendent vers la
primaire de la droite en opérationnel la
gauche on en est pas là aujourd'hui mois
m'adressant à travers vous aux
françaises et aux français qui nous
regardent
je le redis et la certitude que ce que
nous engageons c'est pas pour nous faire
plaisir
c'est pour améliorer votre vie
quotidienne c'est ça qui est important
est ce que ça marche assez non parce
qu'il faut appeler un chat un chat
parce qu'on peut pas être dans le déni
est ce que nous pensons que ça va aller
mieux oui est ce que la politique
économique et sociale menée par ce
qu'est ce qui ce gouvernement doit
changer non françois hollande a lié son
destin à la version la courbe du chômage
si cette courbe ne s'inverse pas et à
partir de quel moment d'ailleurs c'est
une question vous pensez qu'il pourra
dès qu'il dira je n'y vais pas l'eau non
mais moi je ne suis pas à la place de
françois hollande je discute je n'en ai
pas
je n'avais pas les capacités et je peux
vous dire mais de façon les plus
sincères mais je sais bien que les
polémistes ne crois pas ça je parle pas
pour vous je parle pour les politiques
les polémistes crois pas ça mais moi je
vois régulièrement françois hollande en
réunion ou en privé je n'ai jamais
entendu parlé une seule fois d'élection
présidentielle 2017 jamais y compris sur
la primaire nous avons une opposition
j'ai même lu parfois que il était à
l'elysée que à l'elysée je sais pas qui
c'est que françois hollande pourrait
participer à la primaire il ne nous a
jamais parlé
aujourd'hui nous parlons terrorisme nous
parlons code du travail
nous parlons sociale nous parlons
jeunesse nous parlons éducation nous
parlons formation et il est à sa tâche
jusqu'au bout le reste ne vous intéresse
pas et puis à la fin de l'année il
prendra sa position à l'automne à la fin
de l'année et puis en fonction de cette
position s'il est candidat je ferai
partie de ce jeu parce que nous ne
serons nombreux qu'ils soutiendront
primaire ou pas primaire et moi je vous
ai dit que je n'étais pas favorable
parce qu'il va pas aller battre le pavé
à deux c'est pas pour débattre avec les
copains enfin il a autre chose à faire
que d'aller battre les estrades et elle
que prépare et que tu rappes faire son
travail de chef de l'état et puis s'il
n'y va pas mais là il y aura une
primaire où je sais pas dans quel camp
se fera une joie diront qu'ils ne
pensaient de l'option maquis sera levé
reprises et tout à l'heure de commenter
les propos prêtés au ministre de
l'économie sur la réforme du droit du
travail
on sait que voilà je vais bien se
prépare on a l'impression en fer en tous
les cas la presse l'a senti comme cela
là je vais vous répondre très
sincèrement je n'en sais rien je ne sais
pas qui sera candidat dans ce cas là
enfin ce que je pense c'est que si
françois hollande
n'allez pas à l'élection présidentielle
de 2017 pour une loi pour une autre
qu'il choisisse ou qu'ils ne puissent
pas y aller ou je ne sais trop
on serait dans une telle situation
politique que après il faudrait si et
quand même me semble-t-il de nous serrer
les coudes et de sauver les meubles et
une candidature d'arnaud montebourg qui
a également évoqué régulièrement et
qu'il a pour le coup pour être face à
françois hollande
il a arrêté la politique qu'il est dans
le privé peut-être reviendra-t-il je ne
sais pas s'il a envie de se croyez pas
ces rumeurs de retour
non mais moi je ne crois en a aucune
aucune rumeur il ya solutré à beuvry jeu
mais pas les deux sur le même plan parce
que c'est lui qui est monté sous les
traits pendant des années il a été
président de la république et il avait
une carrure françois mitterrand
absolument énorme mais le sujet n'est
pas là on verra montebourg amant
d'autres peut-être martine aubry marie
noëlle lienemann notre collection
adresse a annoncé qu'elle est inattendue
avoir vingt candidats à l'élection
présidentielle
le sujet n'est pas là c'est comme ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui à droite enfin le
spectacle qui sera donné par la droite
et par la gauche
six à douze candidats de droite et une
dizaine de guérillas de gauche
vous savez je vais vous dire une chose
ce n'est c'est un sentiment personnel
pas du tout une attaque vis-à-vis de qui
que ce soit mais je ne crois pas un
instant qu'il y ait une douzaine de
membres des républicains capable d'être
président de la république comme une
douzaine de socialistes capables de
président de la république capable
d'être kaneda la candidature à une
primaire oui mais être président de la
république dans l'état où en est on avec
une europe grandes mines envoyé quand
elle mange non mais moi je dis peut y
avoir il peut y en avoir deux ou trois
des républicains qui ont la carrure et
je pense que aujourd'hui à gauche parce
qu'il est président de la république
c'est françois hollande qui est le mieux
à même de faire de faire cela et s'il
essaie de ne pas l'être
nous avons la chance d'avoir des talents
et nous choisirons parmi deux ou trois
talons merci à vous merci stéphanie me
merci à vous bonsoir a très vite
et